ah sure
this is a Rob's dream for sure yeah
what's up guys I'm Eric that's Rob as
you can see in the lower thirds uh today
we're gonna revisit kind of like a an
older game it did get an update last was
October yeah octobrush a World of
Warplanes so we're gonna check out this
new update because Rob said it's pretty
cool and he loves you know flying planes
as most people know namely world war two
planes world war two planes you're gonna
educate me today about the cool ones I
guess and the ones that are not so high
educate I'll know more or less just me
pointing and and gushing over gushing a
good appropriate words Jerry yeah over
these please show me your joystick he
says oh it's the standard Joshua's the
standard logitech it's the best bang for
your buck I mean it's like $40 and it's
been around for like I think I want to
say like a decade it's pretty funny but
hey what are you gonna pick one of the
biggest changes in the 2.0 update was
that they added a concourse mode I guess
so you can kind of further elaborate
yeah I like tell me more about that
so um yeah I mean actually like ages ago
I was able to play like the pre-alpha of
this game in it and I dropped off for a
while but during that time it was you
know very much like World of Tanks which
is like kind of like Last Man Standing
elimination so that's it's it's almost
like a rebel club that right but they
decided to like shift gears with this
update and just do like respawns and
more strategic stuff not just rich
dogfighting more like interacting with
AI like so you're you're getting capture
points say like a airbase you're then
able the airbase to send in bombing runs
ai bombing runs on the enemy base and
like repair your planes and respawn
faster if you'd like command center I
think they launched like v2 rockets at
like an enemy base so and it's it's all
obviously then correlated to like I
don't know that the form of action
points whatever it is you know the first
one
get to batson like that hello iron
William he's watching from Ostia thanks
for tuning in I'm Batman watching from
the USA thank you guys all for tuning in
I'll be monitoring chat so throw your
questions my way to send over to rob as
he has a dog playing four statements yes
like it's like real kam dog says world
war two plans are cool I think someone
else said that I wish there was oh it's
Batman I wish there's more ww2 World War
two playing games yeah I agree
playing are we in right now I'm in a
Messerschmitt Bf 109 G okay it's kind of
like the top tier yeah as will world war
ii like occurred you know you have your
base plane and they would to find ways
of upgrading it or like manipulating it
for like different roles right like if
it's a multi purposed plane you would
you know have rocket science oh we can
do ground targets or maybe it's just
strictly like an air defense plane which
you would do you guys all generally like
do you feel like you're all generally
going towards this one point to capture
it or do you do you feel like there's
like different teams that'll break off
to do other like to get others I think
ideally yeah like and there's this boat
is interesting someone else I don't have
my hockey's rules yeah yeah because like
now that is so territory based and like
it seems like some of these territories
or different places you can capture seem
to have more effect on the field and
whatnot do you guys like I see like a
lot of your team mostly kind of going to
I guess you guys just captured something
and then there's like now a lot of the
red team's going after this midpoint
where you're flying into and someone's
gonna okay good you're about to you're
about to run into a firefight here
how do you say AI so yeah you're right
in the sense of I think you would you
know if not using chat you're kind of
looking at the mini-map and you're
gauging like okay so say I see the enemy
has captured an airbase well it's
probably best that I go to that Air Base
because I think everybody says one of
the things that you would want Bronn is
not getting the way Rob you can gauge
bombing runs nice that's all right
okay maybe it's not all right no smoked
all right I view that as a trade sure
let's look at the map here but yeah and
also to think about an airbase is that
your respawn rate is increased
I have no know so like that's that's a
big deal so let's see let's try to so
you actually want to try to get that
probably want to go here oh and in this
map looks like I can like I think also
if you have the airfield it says that
you can select a respawn point from
where intercom reenter combat which is
seems like a pretty big deal so that's
cool yeah there's also the plant to get
three influence points so okay so that's
finally influence points points okay
military base conducts a rocket strike
for instance here so Kojo is attacking
our airfield I'm gonna take his ass Wow
you get him this is your airfield Rob
not his thing also he's by himself wow
this guy is intriguing and there's a
wall we have ai ai ai ai in those days
the Jukes air brake punch it lead those
shots rub stay on target
ooh-ooh-ooh fires can turn pretty well
apparently but he can't get rid of you
Rob oh he's close yeah I think I think I
got his engine he's giving you a little
that was a risky move on my part and
clearly it's working would you go in
there he didn't destroy me
I just tried myself that's a weird blame
but he essentially destroyed oh man how
did so how did they get the airfield
there I thought there was only one guy
there there may have been other people
okay so yeah we're gonna take back okay
so like to capture territories you know
at the beginning of each other all key
territories are neutral controlled by
their local Defense Forces you must your
team must establish control over the
territory by destroying targets within
its scope within it like ground objects
oh oh that's hot that's real hot I don't
want a camera fun yeah
redo that match was working out yeah it
wasn't like ground objects air defense
aircraft and enemy team planes and then
that'll get you capture points go back
can I do we're going to wha
what's the name of the game it's World
of Warplanes this is a free play game I
do have a press account that they were
gracious enough to give me and was able
to expedite the process quite sure how
long I'll have the account babe
I guess it's a cool way of looking at
like late game if you were to invest the
time what's up pro Bros TV Josh
funny enough he's asking have you
checked out star citizen update 3.0
that's interesting we were talking about
so I have it installed I have to take a
look at it you know we have to make a
call
because despite that game like on this
PC like running it does run and that
update sounds amazing
the issue is the framerate like I I can
handle it I find it playable but I want
to get some opinions here in the office
before we decide to make a stream
because when it drops to 10 it's not
enjoyable for anyone to watch so we'll
have to see but I would love to stream
that game because I've josh's in the
chat we've had some good times
Oh nailed it three to play hey to win
we'll try to see how much you accrue
from like one match I think you can okay
crap like so here's here's what I will
say is like I did max out a plane
because yes that is always a concern
with anything right and I don't know
like I'm not horrible at flying and
dogfighting but like I didn't see that
big of a change right like it's you
still have to like have some skill like
regardless yeah and I don't I don't see
it like detracting too much I don't know
that's I mean like this is very
different comparison but I kind of
didn't see the huge difference in
Battlefront I felt like skill was still
oh you're absolutely right yeah but like
I'm sure it's still helped as you had
mentioned
yeah and it's it's also just the case of
like Oh
Oh
Oh I'm close real close look like you
shredded him that's why I thought he
died there so there is health regen if
he is not taking damage
I see so here's the thing he's got a
good tactic here he's in a jet so he's
about speed he just has to do like hit
and runs but I would not devise Wow do
this a bold man or have you played war
thunder I guess a while ago I haven't I
haven't checked into it so the war
thunder is I would say like the exact
same and and as far as like you know
it's leave it's free-to-play as well
like I believe there's more
single-player types up in war thunder ok
sorties and like custom like
single-player experiences but I don't
okay I don't know if this is better than
the best playing game or is worth better
so I really haven't like gone back to
those games that's fair I mean a lot of
people are saying some people are saying
they like war thunder more that's the
actual general comparison right now or a
question is how I mean it's hard not to
compare to world war 2 planes they're
both free to play
I think there's those are both Russian
companies as well Mizzou tire tie u GP
says uh depends on your preference war
thunder is on the simulator realism side
where yeah that's why is like kind of
fully arcade yeah and I think that's why
this update is worth maybe taking a look
at because that's kind of what where
they were at previously it was like no
strictly good dogfighting here it's like
right now alright I don't have to like
get into it like a head-on mattress like
another player what I can do is I can
help out my team by like you know
offering support and taking down bombers
is there really only three bombers three
I don't know someone's saying that like
at first they weren't so happy about the
fact that this game they're different
hunters so I think each country has like
three bombers okay and they are updating
the one bomber they don't have is a
Stuka that you're second second yeah
it's like a dive
that Germany had did what you could Rob
get back to the base I have not let's do
a bomber
I mean bombing I was thinking about it
today like balmy is cool but I think it
requires one a lot of patience and it's
also not as interesting to someone
watching because I mean what are you
doing you're just flying you're hitting
ground targets right you know I'm liking
it like a tense dogfight latest bright
as mentioned just now from the GD is in
the game
it's what the Stukas actually in the
game that's what someone's telling you
in chat that was Mizzou Toyo GP for
latest bright though from what the chat
said the difference would be that one's
kind of more Arcadian ones more kind of
like right simulator realism which is
this one so know if you have interest
but you're not like or you're
intimidated like this is the this might
be one to get into yeah and then that
the name is the name because world of
you know tanks port is it world World of
Tanks
yes yeah sorry this World of Warplanes
obviously so like the same company
therefore like the name is that's the
name I don't see it
Stukas I'm here where is this Stuka it
ain't here
what's up NH alright let's play again
okay let's do it
let's change my plan now we do bombing
let's do bombing there let's do a fire
Spitfire no it's it's a you have to
download their installer there
wait oh I mean Spitfires new KD upset
gaming raba actually just enjoys I think
playing games or just the ability to
flying a flight game yeah I like flying
really so I thought he told me I have 80
hours of actual flight exploring to get
my license and during college and
eventually because you know Joo was
going through that to write I think he
did get through Scantlin that yeah just
an old friend used to be a giant yeah I
it takes a lot of investment I could
probably do it now I still want to some
point it's just like I was taking like
21 like units in college trying to
graduate and then there was no way I had
time to like do all the written portion
which is extensive like weights and
balances you need to know when you get
into playing like you can't just like
take off have you played world of
warships I haven't no I hadn't say I
didn't see footage like that
sorry Bruno we don't have too much to
say on that one yeah that was the most
recent like of there yeah I don't even
know if it's like out of beta or okay so
he says Stuka Joo 87 tier 5 German
ground attack aircraft on the right side
of the penguin we'll have to check that
out thank you
get your Rica I did not see it I must be
blind gaming with mix not sure if
there's gonna be a console release
unfortunately I don't have information
on that sorry
[Music]
according to our boy mizu Taiyo GP
assuming i'm saying your name right tell
me if i'm not there's a dev QA which
says that the steam release is coming
soon and the devs want to improve on the
pc version first before porting to
console Thank You
Majeed Ziad is the game worth to invest
time on it I mean I think that since
it's free-to-play it's pretty easy for
you to kind of hop into a couple games
and try it
play it see if you like it and I think
that'll be your determining factor of if
you want to get into it I think Rob is
enjoying the newer mode a little bit
more than he did with the you know
previous no I don't know am i putting
words in your mouth no not necessarily
okay I think this mode is is definitely
like
it's more diverse but there was
something about what about elimination I
did like okay granted it's you know the
unfortunate case case with the
elimination is like oh no you can
operate out of the menu and get back at
you think about hub G right you actually
get back in the game pretty quick okay
but it was this really tense because I
had like when I was planning to play off
for like X rounds or something like that
no no it's just like elimination based
there was one man I had like when I just
work out curse and I was in the
pre-alpha and I had this one moment it
was like me verse nine and I pulled it
off like went into canyons I was able to
like shake I'm gonna have him crashed
into bridges and stuff and it was just
the most exhilarating thing like in my
entire life
wow the entire life my heart was racing
me verse nine or like am I actually
gonna do this was crazy
but yeah I mean it be cool to go back to
that mode I mean but no cuz I don't
think you can I don't think that mode of
existence game here
oh boy shared someone know I'm [ __ ] been
looking getting chased now according to
the map or maybe no I know that's what
I'm saying right here this guy is on
your six robbed sinister Wolfie not
anymore
we're on the hunt now
oh yeah
how do you like that sinister wolf oh
damn it shake you this is the Spitfire
earlier yeah do you remember Eric do you
remember it's got some sublime
maneuverability
let's see Keith Richards liver 420 says
what three planes that the British have
in this
I've heard of theirs was in the best in
World War two were this big bears the
best planes and World War two yeah oh
that's debatable eyes debatable land she
say the Germans the Germans had some
damn good planes yeah yeah they were the
first to make they had the first jet
airplane that's in this game but the
problem is like for another war they
were like investing all their time and
effort into making these jets and not as
many planes so to speak so they're
putting like teenagers into these jets
and they're you know they're like really
good planes but they're getting shot
down so like towards the end of the war
they like didn't have any where much of
the airforce like people wasted like the
Japanese zero is like no awesome plane
p-51 Mustang which we have is what we
have well they say it won the wall
because was able to escort bombers into
Germany need to get that auto heal and
there we go
we repair in the skies yeah now if we
mentioned that earlier so yeah like you
can you have health regeneration if you
are not taking
just as nice only I think the halfway
there looks like it's gonna stop
yeah as mentioned maajid the easiest way
is probably just to Google World of
Warplanes and Google and you'll probably
get the launcher to download it
hello Nicole Brown there we go hope is
back yeah that's right he's not going
after you look after someone's gonna
have some times I'm gonna help my buddy
but if I move oh you got killed by him
oh dami
I thought I was following him nowhere
see I began I'm beginning to think I
actually suck at this game like what do
you mean you've been I've been getting
killed kills but like I would say that
you're at least one to one so I should
be in the worst case you're always
getting one oh man you guys are kind of
getting dominated some saying it would
take something let's go take this no
yeah this guy's got a shore home aunt
Meg wall this is World of Warplanes with
the 2.0 update that came out last
October
Jesus honey guys are here
yeah but we got a lot of stuff coming on
the the weeks we got games coming out
soon a couple betas on the way metal
gear survive will be next week
unfortunately I don't know how we're
gonna do Dragon Ball because Monday's a
holiday and it didn't actually come out
it's not gonna come out tomorrow like we
thought we were it was gonna so it's
gonna come out I think Saturday if you
have early access and then open on
Sunday Monday ends on like Tuesday 12
a.m. one day going into Tuesday Monster
Hunter beta once 100 world baby next
week as well and then Monster Hunter
world and Dragon Ball fighters will
close cannot to see you so gonna have to
figure that out
so back camera changing Oh yep of course
do there like so many dudes here shake
them
boomerang man I'm really liking this
Spitfire
yeah I'm liking that liking all the I'm
just on him dude except you're like
tickling them
yeah doesn't how much Python play the
might 94 d Starfire in the u.s.
multi-role tech tree that's here take
make sure to fully upgrade it using free
experience and get them Vulcan minigun
lots of fun this is coming from our our
guy that's a World of Warplanes battery
oh I I have Molly tired that might be
the he's gonna tell someone to follow us
personally no sir what nothing okay I
believe goob that the the Dragonball
fighters beta this weekend will be open
I want to say as of Sunday let me double
check that though
sinister wolf open beta will be on Gary
or 14 did you get the wolf
we got the wolf and we got the airfield
is there a rank mode at all
not yet okay question was answered thank
you
what is this right here I don't know my
hockey format the only the shield it's
probably good at the armory or something
let me see it barracks garrison I can
find out for you rod house I can
probably find out the map for you too
maybe
oh bomber group well let's take military
base the plants in the airfield I
actually don't know which one that one
is could be
yeah we could damn
oh are you gonna try to get the Snuka
can't question was that sorry
the wakow solo what's up hello welcome
to the chat and welcome to the stream
right what did I tell you yet did you
let me go back I know he said oh you did
yeah you sure I don't feel like you dude
bottom right and the tech tree
okay yeah German ground on the right
side of the texture II on German ground
attack aircraft oh how did I miss that
cuz you're a noob I don't know thanks
again thank you thank you
time for the Stuka so again we do have
Joel Batista we haven't played enough to
get a press count so I'm able to I don't
know the actual rate of like how okay
that's fair we haven't played enough
warthunder to compare the two so
unfortunately I can't give you which one
they're super similar though I mean like
a few years ago my plates are damn yeah
they're similar I guess it's just the
experience you want cuz as the chat
Ismet had mentioned earlier one's kind
of more simulator realistic versus this
one World of Warplanes is a little bit
more arcadey so yeah we got any cool
pain but the the beauty of it is I
believe they're both free to play so you
could probably just figure that out
yourself if you just play a few matches
of both oh do we get any cooling nose
art no look at that
yep sure sure don't like it thank you
for my game let's do it let's let's go
on a bombing run I said you could also
put like I should've done it you can put
like cannons on these opposed are just
bombs or like anti-tank cannons uh-oh it
says for the Jew 87 upgrade the or the
Ju 87 upgrade the guns to 37 millimeter
guns otherwise it sucks thank you very
much
we're doing that Lonnie couldn't conics
Lonnie conics when game so I finally
brings someone who knows how to play
what yeah Danny wire is that you know
definitely not our boy DoD it's just
glorious
are we going all out what's up what was
the UM the millimeter 37 millimeter okay
I got
I think boo mount that alright yeah
doesn't talk about those anti-tank look
at those plans cool sorry is this the
one that you said was your favorite it's
one it's like one of your top fives yeah
so I don't I can never remember the name
of it you can really look it up okay but
this plane it like basically set the
precedent for like whenever a point you
see a plane dive in movies it has it
like let's like siren-like our planes
were actually like normally not that
many of them like actually do that but
this plane I wanna see is called her to
rot the drama Geronimo
siren scream they be Germans basically
put like propellers on the landing gear
so when it like I thought when I did it
I they would like Geronimo
trumpets Jericho yeah and it would just
it was meant to basically just terrorize
people on the ground it's not on ps4
it's not a console yet unfortunately so
but you can play for free on PC so you
wanna check it out have fun sick is the
longest I've had away yeah now that you
got sick me playing just cuz I pimped it
out you picked a ride no it's just
putting me into your queue
I'm just gonna try again okay you do
that was this the plane in Dunkirk I
have not watched dunker probably I can't
believe it oh you haven't seen I'm
fairly sure if it's yeah I would say
definitely there this plane was like
pretty predominant war thunder /
jungkook sounds like a Stuka yep Stuka
Dunkirk actually the seasons moving
because I'm such a douche in actual fact
the sound was specific to Stuka
dive-bombers
and was created by wind it driven sirens
on the wheel struts so there you go
Dunkirk don't read any it's rough in
there yeah apparently the J the Ju 87
Stuka was effective and morale
destroying that do that that's a pretty
terrifying somebody thought to do that I
know that's so freakin great sounds
really like scary this let's put it on
the plane how do terrorize Oh do we get
anyone I recommend that you just staying
queue yeah just resets and you have to
wait twice as long now we're good right
thank you for the tip though
what's the best plane to play when you
start the game you start off with like
the first tier I believe and then you
have to research as you go along but so
yet you you would want to like pick a
country and probably start the game by
investing time into like specific plans
like plan ahead right like alright you
know I really want this like bf109 wolt
I'll just like stick to one tech tree
and just keep upgrading it and no one
said it was a Spitfire and Doug Kurt
yeah well that's the British plane
Bruno we're using a 1080 that's a nice
big junior hope you're enjoying it
what's up Farex Derek's a cat Felix he
says hey Tay and Rob you guys watch
every Blue Angel show an SF I don't but
Rob does oh oh do i my birthday lines up
every weekend like just in time for
Fleet Week here in the city so for
instance I had a blue Angel 30th
birthday party yep I'm sorry you didn't
come
I got it kind of oh I apologize
maybe so gamers saying for him it
crashes every four to five matches and
apparently it's the same on the forums I
don't know
we had one crash so far we'll see how
many matches we go tastes too cool to
show up maybe do a barrel roll sorry
wait am I in that planer that you see
you buy her something nice good yeah
you're in it oh yeah there's a gunner
seat how can I control it oh I have to
control with this oh yeah I'm back there
yep no one's know anything again on your
six oh dude oh dude listen to that oh
there we go yeah get on my six I dare
you
this doesn't work
you shouldn't need to have one
damnit
get him Rob
how effective is that back turret in
saving you here out of here it doesn't
look very very effective my friend
yeah well flying in a straight line is I
don't know how often I don't know how I
should have been doing now
I should have been flying screw that
Jarret oh yeah that was an old game ill
to Sturmovik oh yeah I never played it
but I hear pelipper great things about
it
I used to play a lot of Ju 87 as a
ground attack plane it generally means
that you need to play the ground and
destroy grounds are cool thank you great
tip we on it hey man he's the he's a
World of Warplanes veteran man I got a I
got a let him well said avoid the dog
and destroy all the targets within a
sector within the target right well
let's what to do that alright let's try
this again
do you think we'll get to hear the sound
find out right no it didn't even look
like the propellers are on it
it's up Leon I'm not gonna say oh I
think that's too much I feel like I've
been butchering everyone's last name or
like second part oh wow oh all right
it's not just me that I'm seeing these
green tracers okay
good thing you're here Rob with the
knowledge actually Dan you do work my
turret is dude you could take some
damage though man I know right it's a
bomb baby I'm not like those little
planes you're just not it's like a tower
a guard tower or something nice yeah oh
yeah yeah no worries thanks for the
advice oh yeah appreciate it I really do
I mean I yeah I'm I'm not gonna try to
pretend I never saw this game yeah of
course
no I want to show do your job Rob it
doesn't matter if there's an enemy on
your tail man it's all good pelipper I
am older than you think did I see
did I say 30 and people said I'm old no
they were just saying that yeah
oh that's awesome says the merio married
video game Aaron that was pretty awesome
little little right hey we're doing a
lot better this map yeah we're like one
node we don't have to see where I wasn't
that scoreboard though oh really
so like I believe if you get if you
capture an airbase you can sit I can it
allows you to swap planes if you don't
have the airbase you can so I could I
could say like we needed more like air
superiority air support your superiority
like like taking out an actual like you
know it's dogfighting I could like swap
to like a plane that would be good at
that I believe it's the
case victory closed Rob you really hit
him oh I mean I think I'm in range
like a bad idea
we were supposed to avoid dog fights
well I can move in a little bit no it's
too far I think when their icons are
like glowing is one of them in range
tempted oh there's a guy Kaname
just missed that Spitfire turn I'm not
sure Junior if you should get the I 778
20 HK fortunately I can't tell you I'm
injured you're so good you're destroyed
by Graz Bob so do we have an air base
here that is that bottom left one the
air base we won we won at her dope
I can't wait for a return we died how
old is Eric that's a good question
how old is Eric how old are you
Pella 4 says hey Rob if we're the same
age I guess it's ok I thought you were
younger born in 88 87 oh boy he said
nice try
I'm younger than Rob no no I believe
that no let's take a look at a different
plane how about the yeah what do you
guys the first jet ever sick or I know
that's necessarily true but the first
one in World War 2 those views and which
ones this one sorry - 6 - the
Messerschmitt 262 let's check it out I
should do anything with it
let's see you upgrade you tell me I
don't know oh it's got oh oh oh do it oh
dude it's got freaking rockets let's do
it
which I put anything on this summer
summer paint you know not even summer
right you're right but it's oh I think
these are Auto to the map so if it's
like a snow map it'll auto like oh it's
gonna pick this whoa I'm into it
something like armored warfare that also
got recently updated I'm not sure hard
to say maybe maybe not
f-94 starfire is a great plane to try
fully upgraded with the Vulcan of course
that must be his plane man pelipper yeah
you're not that you're not I'm 40 cat
asking what will we be streaming
tomorrow hard to say I have two ideas
one is gonna be dependent on Rob testing
something to see if it works out if it
doesn't have a back-up plan I'm gonna
show you the game okay and you you'll
have to make the call what do I have
it's call you make the call we both make
the call right we both like the call on
whether it's worth it streaming because
like the thing is there are just it's
not like consistent like 10 frames even
lowers also tips that you need other
people to make it funnier or are you
good by yourself fine
I think all we need is us in the chat
all right that's pretty good guessing
table winging it tomorrow no I have a
plan regardless of if Rob's game falls
through its Carson yes our citizen is
his uh is what he's recommended but what
see I mean okay so they had that like
huge update yeah the 3.0 which allows
you to like do like actual
interplanetary like landings from space
and stuff so don't agree knowns yeah
sure okay now not like that procedurally
generated I think they're dirty look at
this dude
yeah Dark Souls remastered coming to all
consoles and PC and the switch dude my
Mario Tennis yeah sure my tennis is fine
but I saw about Virtua Tennis did people
know that game that game was great its
arcade game and on the flight on
Dreamcast but yeah I'm looking forward
to that spudley Dudley I actually
haven't played ds1 to or Demon Souls and
we played blood-borne and ds3 so
probably checking out the Dark Souls
remastered also still curious what that
from software game is some people
speculate like don't you there's a bunch
of other stuff Oh baby oh you aren't
flying now can you imagine being in a
propeller plane and then this thing just
shows up like the first time that
actually happened the war like just
flies are fighting in your sleep oh my
god what was that was this a good plane
though yeah it was pretty - plane yeah
- I mean like it you just couldn't catch
it like I imagine that like it would it
would intercept bombers and just be out
that's not the me-262 though this isn't
that's the me-109 TL is what DJ bol says
Shh no it's not I picked it my man let's
see me Zoot I yeeah GP is saying 109 TL
is basically a budget at 262 on the
basis of the bf 109 I know we got some
eye hot plane can't I can't argue can't
argue that and he said pretty beast yeah
we'll see I don't know I'm not I'm not
even gonna try to say I know anything
about World War 2 planes
I'm just here for the chat I just got
out matched really oh boy that's the
case I had no idea this means they look
almost identical where's your plan here
I don't know it's not going totally well
oh there's pay ha mr. job Rob what oh no
I just mashed it oh it already dropped
oh god okay I don't know if I did
anything oh no I'm not looking at my
mini map room game distract you should
be faster than those propeller planes
you got nice nose hold down tab and
check the name on your plane me-109 all
right
well then that's what the chats for you
know we test the chat every now and then
to make sure you know you guys know
what's up you know and it's good to know
chats got your back
for the most part chats always had her
back there's only been a handful of
times where I felt the trade and
mistakes were made like what they say
like one time I was in a long-ass queue
for overwatch oh yeah in the hash and
then and then I was like what do you
guys think should we stay in the the
keyword or should we leave everyone was
like unanimously unanimously saying
leave and rejoin and that was a great
mistake
got him was just a different fuselage
different wings cetera they look similar
on a superficial level so you know that
looks so similar he capitalized that hey
never trust chat is saying that we why
we have Ellery uh who knows spudley
Dudley I think Demon Souls will happen
remake before Kingsfield though that's
for sure oh oh what's up dude notice are
the factions locked to each map where
can you pick whatever plane you want I
think you basically you have to start
off picking the plane you want right
factional no yeah it's all up in the air
okay that's right there is no like
faction specific map I mean it's my
knowledge I'm pretty sure there's not a
cyborg man says I'm gonna keep it real
with you today but war thunder is better
than this that's fair totally fair if
you enjoy that game war I don't have a
basis to talk about both well enough so
I just abstain and let the chat decide
the only difference I've been told by
chat is that one's more arcadey than the
other so just depend on which don't have
a game think you can pick whatever you
want it's based on tears now we'll
country the planes are front the me-262
just came too late into the war yeah
like it was there was no need like they
were like dope planes but they didn't
have the budget to like make the plane
so they went all in
so they so you look at in this respect
like they probably had like I want to
say maybe thirty of these things tops at
one point or something like that is
where I think I'm right either you make
thirty of these or how about like a
thousand other planes right like there
was no point in investing money to this
my audio just got really low oh yeah I
get to it back up okay
that makes it let's turn down an audio
on that head on that headphone audience
he gave all and any szu tai o UD are
telling us how Pablo and the chat how
the repairs work as long as you have the
air base field and you're within it and
there aren't any enemies around it you
should start to get repaired yeah
smoke these bombers is this a satisfying
and when you kill like runs in titanfall
2 you shot way to go Rob toast dude but
you accomplished your job which is to
take out those bombers do you have a
repair field ok you got spit fired I
done got spit fire God we have the
repair field um believe that's the one
in the middle so you're at the bottom of
the list but you have a decently high I
wasn't looking so someone else says also
wants to see the f94 d so I guess we'll
just have to upgrade that point in later
we will get the f94 D I get the Vulcan
cannon on it that's what they want we'll
do that next game once we yes yeah we'll
do it soon 5 minutes immediately fire
extinguish
destroy them rub the Baba's you do you
you do what feels best in your heart cuz
I got Rockets baby let them rip no man
you got oh I should've been eased ain't
you got a bomb now left targets here I
can shoot that no oh we got it we got
our base oh sweet
ok so in theory that would I think I'd I
think that I did it yeah you did it I
think that's what happened we're not
gonna crash into the hills no wait
cyborg around I mean what is your
favorite World War 2 plane
mine is the Spitfire good plane good
choice what you always nice to the 109
the first plane
mine is D I don't know because I'll go
at the StuCo cuz it has a cool noise
nailed it legit yeah it's got cool noise
there you go it lowered morale as it as
it killed people untitled i stalled and
my engines overheated those are not good
things you need some you need some of
your boys to help get this guy off your
back oh they're on it they're on it raw
he's freaking out looking I'm freaking
out are you tagging them a little bit
there yeah I think I did this guy's on
them too man you are like they all got a
van I'm gonna get out of here they are
in like a sports car
I'm in like an odyssey
a souped-up Odyssey it's got a meaty
cannon though yeah it does right your
engine has overheated that's fine
look at this guy doing barrel rolls this
starfox I like my plains burnt to a
crisp finish him did you get him you got
the Johnson middle class for I did send
you an Avenger oh man you guys are
getting smoked now yeah this games in
terms of territory so you're just gonna
try to accrue some hot experience by
blowing up these bombers sure you got to
defend the sector as well you've been
tasked with got him get back to the base
Rob get the hell out of there Oh get the
f94 okay all right with a vole Concannon
okay I just got to make sure it happens
okay that's how it goes oh this is
normal for you
I haven't been okay cool loading loading
I want to see one thing
- 60 - 60
f94 right yeah f94 with the voices hey
there's a plan you still done goo it
looks pretty different they gusto looks
pretty different oh it totally has the
109 canopy yeah I yeah I take it back
actually
when did I amateur guys it's been a
while
all right what's good this f94 what
country is it F would be you say 594
bingo 94 D let's just research our way
to it we got to research dan you got
that money to buy I'll look at jet we'll
get there Bronwen nope wrong one cut
damn it
CID Kapoor if we have time we'll try the
f4u Corsair that's good plan that's
what's up Lucas why is that good plane
yeah that was like in using Pacific
Theater you'd be like right here the
wings would fold up it's what you see on
like aircraft carriers this guy knows
what's up I don't know nothing
how are you how are you doing good
and we're there we're gonna look at this
Concannon man I don't even know what
that means but it's right here we need
to get it let's let's check it out okay
that's fine that's it that's why you
have at least one expert do you have the
f-84 saber no okay let's put the vulcan
on we can't afford it hmm we're lucky oh
you're just getting everything sure okay
that engine yeah okay let's just let's
rock let's let's rock and roll
or do we want to put a cool little paint
job on damn paint man a little uh pretty
lady no worry Lucas I'll try to decipher
anything you say we pay to win no we the
generous folks at wargaming gave us a
press account to take a look at this
game to see you know what it's about
and yeah we were able to get to this
plane and it's supposed to be real good
yeah well we'll see so it's a higher
tier so generally you're matched with
other tiers so that's that's a nice
thing obviously you don't want to start
the game in a biplane and get worked by
jet it sounds like a fun time what did I
get just like I'll play them be ready
Rob alright let's let's check the wow
yeah alright pretty sure this wasn't in
a little war - but it goes up like I
think like 1950 1960s touch planes look
at this thing don't forget to buy the
modules you researched researching them
alone doesn't do a whole lot
I didn't equip them did I what's bounced
out oh you would you would return to the
hangar sorry thanks for spotting that
they're just so hurry okay yeah what
nothing not gonna read it it's pretty
funny though I find it funny yeah you
guys may have unlocked it but you didn't
buy it
Thanks appreciate it
you're some battle oh really
damn it I thought oh the plane itself is
in battle yeah you're doing I done this
up totally uh well let's fly someone
else Wow can you do the course there
nailed it
sure let's do the Corsair Wow fail well
that's a good way to get people to not
just like leave a game I guess fail
whatever we're making time here we get
given this course here some love oh yeah
Ace Combat 7 will be all I'm really
excited for that also that is how the V
are all part of it 100% man in my
opinion like that is that's where like V
are just works is any time you're like
situated in a cockpit or a seat like
driving games you know I mean like it
works and god I don't even know this
says 2018 I don't even know if there
there's gotta be some airplane I mean I
have not played a an airplane game no
x-wing Glee VR mission actually it is
pretty cool that worked because this is
neat like you know you get to look
around and like follow someone and then
like connect your like crosshair to
their position it's it's like really
natural do you not equip them again no
ok welcome was specific to no but I did
you even upgrade anything ok ok
and they forgot to upgrade their plane
yeah it worked so well at the Stuka
smiley face
hey that's - cut that was a fun time
that Jukka that cannon was sweet it's
fine it's cool
I'm just trying to get right back in the
action Eric oh yeah all right except for
when we have to upgrade the Vulcan
except for that oh man this plane is
this game called dota 2 now
unfortunately it is not defenders of the
ancients - it's all game by valve though
originally a frozen world of warcraft 3
Frozen Throne maybe not even frozen
throne I think it's world Warcraft like
used map settings this is on a PC
we're gonna end in that f94 by the way
with Milken yeah I'm gonna end good and
once we actually upgrade didn't care
that there's an enemy on his tail
someone on my tail oh I thought you're
saying this guy also he probably doesn't
really care about anything cuz he's AI
nice
shoot up that than a and beat like a
depo these just all AAA
I'm not checking my mini-map as much as
I should be I'll try to check there's no
red in this area they're all fighting
over the airfield it looks like there's
a lot more red in that airfield they'll
tell you that cool and we'll go all
you're trying to get the UN one other
trying to get this location which I
can't see on the mini-map
unfortunately could be the command no
can't tell okay Joey has been here it's
a heavy fighter
looks like they are they had the
airfield okay we have this let's go get
the airfield I don't think you're gonna
get the airfield let's go this one else
yeah I think you have a better chance of
game the power plant oh they're all over
the airfield right now sky you asked her
that we'll get back to it
let's get some outs
yeah a lot of red there look at that
they're like all there there's one
behind you
I think the corn in the main map
somewhere or maybe he's dogfighting with
someone else
yes go help my boy we got you ice man
we're on our way
what the hell I was at that German
random weird plane if Germans made so
many weird planes what is that
it's like a flying dish I think it's
going to be a recon plane I'm not quite
sure Darcy Darcy blows oh yeah see if
thieves is this month - oh yeah I
thought that was exact correlation there
but made me think to see if these was a
beta right
yeah the beta but does that game ever
really it does that really say I'd have
to look up the actual date can your
plane stall in this yes absolutely so I
would be stalling all time got it where
are you you're dead
local spider I killed you with 94 d
[Music]
that's the american x 5xf 5 you pancake
is that the batwing that's so funny
that's actually what it totally looks
like from a dart Dark Knight Rises
then that thing he has the flying one
come on come on here yeah 11 290 Lars we
didn't get paid anything to play this I
wish no no although in a way I guess
we're getting we choose the games I I'm
a big fan of world war ii plans so i be
a it's been a slow month why not check
out something that had a major update
Robb's all about that plane life I'm
living that plane life alright so how
much more did you say you had to do if
you were to try to get your like flying
license
I had my hours yeah 80 there is no like
set number yeah it's when your
instructor feels comfortable but
generally it's like I heard anywhere
from like 60 to like hundred twenty and
my instructor said you're good and he's
like you're hella good after I die the
same guy
and all I need to do was my written
portion meaning there was a lot of
studying but now it was literally I'm
taking finals at the same time I can't
do this and then I like a slacker having
never gone back to it it's kind of
expensive to actually it is expensive
that's a weird-looking plane too
preparing helping on my team you tell
him to go there let's go there let's go
see what's about it's party
I kept enjoy the arms as I'm taking my
instrument check ride next week damn I
don't know what that means but it must
mean something to you I'm just that's
cool that he's doing that Oh
Landing is the tough part same parallel
parking
Oh like yeah blind it's really tough
like when there's high winds that's the
craziest like when you're making
approaches like or crazy cuz you're
trying to like combat the wind right so
dude that guy is a beast
loco spider yeah that or that plane
maybe with that Vulcan turd is what's
doing the work look at that I'm assuming
goes with a Vulcan
[Laughter]
I'm a licensed pilot after I passed the
check ride I'll be able to fly in zero
visibility weather that's pretty cool
man it's Joey and good luck my
instructor that I had also would teach
aerobatics and knew like how to do like
hammerhead stalls like that and because
of so normally you would kind of long
story but normally you know what you're
getting a prize license you're flying
like Cessna which is like the like those
like more like steering wheel looking
joysticks mm-hmm but because my my
instructor says that I flew a lot of uh
or play a lot of joystick games he was
like oh you should go in this plane and
it was a table Rhea playing that was
outfitted to do like sick aerial moves
and what grade that ish one time he was
like you want to see some cool moves I
was like sure and he just knows dives
and just like a bunch of flips in my
stomach like went through my ass dude it
was like all those G's anyways enough of
that let's do what we were supposed to
do you have to get the ball oh yeah
by that one first again there dude we're
there boom okay let's go I just get all
the way there do it
oh I didn't have to whatever tech trees
am i right
which ones do these look good Eric no
you're the plain guy I'm just here to
read chat and hang out John Cena can fly
in zero visibility
maybe black Moomba this is World of
Warplanes update 2.0 really I spent 76k
on my flight training Yas is the program
the program rippling all the way to my
instructors license houses that's a very
expensive car that's so expensive and
that was the things like the it was a
family friend so like oh wow so you got
it hooked up already I got it like but
even so you're he's like you know he's
like he like gave us a fat discount on
like the lessons but there's so many
things I factor into it fuel the plane
itself you don't buy a plane but you
gotta like you know yeah check it out
engine turns it so many people just
grinded their teeth just now watching me
get those upgrades why I don't know
probably pick all the wrong ones that's
fine thank you guys all again for
watching we are playing World of
Warplanes update 2.0 we're live every
day at 11 a.m.
sans maybe Wednesday for a couple more
weeks here as we are on a little pause
for the lobby for those who know what
the lobby is stay in the queue he said
don't leave the queue
so Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday 11
a.m. come back hang out with us we play
a variety of games
January's been a little bit of a slower
month but it's gonna start picking up
soon got some betas on the way and some
actual game releases on its way so if
you're looking forward to Monster World
or Dragonball Fighters Metal Gear
survive a lot of stuff kind of slowly
coming out for 2018 or stuff obviously
on the way the rest of the year but yeah
mmm-hmm here we go all right hopefully
we got everything we needed because if
not what do we have I didn't get
consumables that's why I don't care this
will be your last match Rob make it a
good one
damn no pressure get me in there hey did
you play any Monster Hunter on the
handheld no I did not I don't have too
many handheld monitor hunter world has
me interested I haven't had time to play
the beta's that were out yet maybe I try
to hop into this next one does seem like
a game that's kind of up my alley kill
stuff loot stuff craft stuff only
problem is Dragon Ball fighters comes
out the same day which is very
unfortunate water-tight yeah
you'd be shocked real cam dog how some
people don't do that
we're heading for it or you just gonna
kind of do what your team's doing here
well I'm not gonna fly straight into the
battle because I feel like that's a big
mistake I want to kind of Coast first
looks like a red team has secured the
garrison my team is pick off some
stragglers possibly doing that team damn
oh it's got Rockets too huh yeah it's
got you got two more sets of them to you
can you and is this or is this just dog
fighting I think she's talking right
yeah you can't win I get it why is it so
lit up look at baby me I do not look
like me yeah someone is definitely on
you oh you are so dead I'm chilling now
you got just destroyed by fire should
have seen that guy come in oh look at
that
that looks nice that's the same thing oh
he's done is it he's got different
cannons then earlier I don't know man I
don't trust
pretty pretty solid pretty solid botch
unfortunately the x-men TIE fighter are
not unlockable take closel but you just
got shot down by a Canadian
edmond
laughter that other guy Rory ooh
see you later Rory
this is this is a heated zone right now
ain't it yeah there's that wheel weasel
Weisel wensel Wenzel he's got a weird
looking playing like a MIG good ol MiG's
how you liking this Vulcan I like it
you can't escape he's just plain parts
are falling all over the sky nice tag
him back
good suggestion chat it's already going
quite well
ooh we're on the hunt burn burn inte
what what how do I get into this view oh
I don't know that's weird
I'm chilling dude okay you're chill this
guy's on shout them out light him up
baby yeah
there's no escape nice we're done I
don't know if you got him though cuz you
didn't get a little pop up there
Yaroslav I know that guy
always going off my boy I can't have
that you check my six okay no one on
your six let me do this
no he's so close to dying what are you
doing yeah sorry I was trying to make my
minimap I'm looking at the mini-map
there you go
there's no definitely no one on your six
oh you guys are clearing them out now
they're they're on the run cue Top Gun
music done
[Music]
dad no not that
yeah that's the danger zone okay fine
highway to the danger zone yes pelipper
would say oh man a lot of activity here
Top Gun was on last night nice could you
die on my six oh yeah sorry I wasn't
doing good jobs looking at chat and I
also in turn just put something on oh
six enemy on your tail maybe you maybe
they started going after someone else
where after you though Wenzel we may
take on Wenzel oh he's on your boy you
better get him off oh yeah yeah that big
kill that wait what Yaroslav wasn't a
MIG though is that the plane or the
turret or the combination of both I
think it's a mainly my skills okay your
skills got a Wallace William Wallace
Oleg yeah a few oh he's like half these
guys I'm starting yeah well sick I got
so much yeah yeah you everything is
correct that was a song from time yeah
it was it was like it was it was I know
it's after they say beat the what's the
Russians I think well whoever they're
their enemy was they like beat them and
the other planes would fly away and it's
like yeah we did it
number one on the carrier's like all
like relax yeah but it's like would you
rather have when you're actually flying
oh yeah you know I'm right sure Oh give
me that
oh that vodka man
his name and can't vodka man looks like
they are deciding to fight somewhere
else because you got the airfield
yeah you're right appears Oh someone's
like to your right somewhere how do they
almost have us we have the airfield
what I don't she's never really gonna
come around my scientist ignore them the
weather looks pretty good to me whoever
that was from HQ oh you guys are in
trouble
this guy
I think someone might be on your six no
he's chasing someone else minds are well
I hope you get to Wenzel before the game
you guys are losing actual war you've
been winning the battles though Rob so
far can he shake you someone's on your
six there's like five planes near you
you're injured Rob you're injured my bad
I was looking at chat for a second and I
didn't see all that wait you're getting
repaired though cuz you're in the air
you're in the air fear and you got it
dude
did you also see there's you in the
plane not doing your job I know I don't
have a back turret to shoot so I kind of
got bored of looking for planes where
are they man all right Rob higher in the
ranking in this game he's definitely
higher oh hey we just needed the right
plane alright
hey that what a way to end it though
right it wasn't gonna get better than
that Rob you know it I know it
thank you guys all for tuning in to
World of Warplanes update 2.0 thank you
to the chat for helping us out given
advice sticking with us chatting with us
we'll be back tomorrow potentially me
and Rob or me and another person yet to
be named depending on the game we play
but really hope you guys have time to
stop by tomorrow and thanks for out for
playing thank you for having me and
everyone have an excellent day it's
almost Friday yeah it's almost Friday
and it's a coming into a three day
weekend for us with MLK so oh thank you
guys all and see you next time happy
hunting